I'm often asked why I have this book
well this book is a piece of American
History it is the book that George W
Bush was reading when 9 11 happened that
morning he was at me Booker Elementary
School in Sarasota Florida following
along as students read his story from
Reading Mastery level 2 storybook 1
rainbow Edition specifically the story
on page 152 The Pet Goat it's about a
little girl who gets a goat that won't
stop budding things at 905 his chief of
staff whispered into his ear a second
plane has hit the second tower America
is under attack and what he later
described as an effort to project
strength and calm Bush continued to sit
and listen to the story for 10 more
minutes critics called it inaction
indecisiveness Michael Moore made the
moment Infamous in Fahrenheit 911 and a
few weeks later Osama Bin Laden jumped
on the incident in an attempt to
embarrass Bush since then many students
and faculty present that day have
defended Bush asking what good it would
have done if he'd rushed out of the room
22 minutes before the Pentagon was
struck the classroom read the final
words of the pet goat more